-Our next guest is nominated for
a Grammy for best new artist.
Performing "FYE FYE" from his
album, "MOMINTS AT THE CRIB,"
with a little help from
Fat Nwigwe,
give it up for Tobe Nwigwe!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Oh ♪
[Rapping] ♪ On God,
I'm extra unique ♪
♪ My whole aura scream talent ♪
♪ I've been listenin' to Fela,
Griselda, and Marvin Winans ♪
♪ Just to make sure
I'm balanced ♪
♪ I'm from the west, yeah ♪
♪ Half of my partners
is savage ♪
♪ The other half made it out
the mud ♪
♪ But the taste of sludge
didn't alter they palate, uh ♪
♪ I'm a dog, I'm a beast,
and yo' father figure ♪
♪ That lil' P365
was just Fat starter pistol ♪
♪ But she got a Scorpion, too ♪
♪ It'll sting you
just like a scorpion do ♪
♪ If a demon get gregarious,
my lil' Harriet don't do ♪
♪ What accordions do ♪
♪ Ooh, that means fold,
I was told by the Gs of old ♪
♪ Ooh, keep yo' lady close,
make sure she can work a pole ♪
♪ But they wasn't referring
to strippers ♪
♪ I'm still bald fade
with the clippers ♪
♪ I done been blessed with
a woman that pray heavy ♪
♪ But turn a freak
on the liquor, uh ♪
♪ She keep the devil off me
like the Cherubim ♪
♪ She make it clear to hoes
that we ain't sharing him ♪
♪ I push the Yukoneezy
like a chariot ♪
♪ DK a legend,
hate we had to bury him ♪
♪ Uh, yeah, but that's how it be
in the jungle ♪
♪ I grew up around wildlings
and mongrels ♪
♪ Ready to slump you,
murk you, or jump you, uh ♪
♪ I rock the slides
to be humble ♪
♪ I told my baby girl she gon'
have more in her head ♪
♪ Than just product
and bundles, uh ♪
♪ They say I'm rappin'
with hunger ♪
♪ I tell 'em hell no,
I'm eatin' ♪
♪ If you book me for a show
and I can't bring my wife ♪
♪ And my babies, I'm leavin',
uh ♪
♪ Big daddy energy speakin',
I keep the enemy tweakin' ♪
♪ I could go "huh" all
on the track and they'll say ♪
♪ I'm the hardest one
breathin' ♪
♪ I am a beacon to heathens,
me and my hood got cohesion ♪
♪ It taught me keep
a lil' .38 special ♪
♪ They bless you when
ain't no one sneezin' ♪
♪ Ahh, this hoe fye, fye ♪
♪ If you Black, we N'SYNC ♪
-♪ Bye, bye, bye ♪
-♪ Everybody say... ♪
-♪ West ♪
-♪ That's my side ♪
-♪ Throw it up, I'm-a put it
down until I die ♪
-♪ One more time, say... ♪
-♪ Ahh ♪
-♪ This hoe fye, fye ♪
♪ If you Black, we N'SYNC ♪
-♪ Bye, bye, bye ♪
-♪ Everybody say... ♪
-♪ West ♪
-♪ That's my side ♪
-♪ Throw it up and I'm-a put it
down until I die ♪
-♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ On God, I'm extra petite ♪
♪ But the hood call me Fat ♪
♪ Fire on me like Shadrach
and Meshach ♪
♪ I keep peace for the scrap ♪
♪ Throw up the... ♪
-♪ West ♪
-♪ Yeah, but let's just keep it
a stack ♪
♪ I was raised in Grand Rapids,
my pops was inactive ♪
♪ My mama was forced to adapt ♪
♪ Uh, she held it down,
that's nothin' new ♪
♪ I'm Black in America ♪
-♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Raised in the slums,
came up from crumbs ♪
♪ Now we cool with Erykah, ooh,
yeah ♪
♪ I'm talkin' Badu, I don't know
why you don't recognize, foo ♪
♪ Me and Tob gon' give and go
just like a drive-through ♪
♪ School of hard knocks
the only thing I applied to ♪
♪ And I got admitted, I ain't
kiddin', ain't it glorious? ♪
♪ I feel like Diddy, Tobe
Biggie, we notorious, yeah ♪
-♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
-♪ But it's so much more to us ♪
♪ Might get a Grammy,
that's the floor to us ♪
♪ Dropped three kids,
lifestyle laborious ♪
♪ Don't need oracles,
I ain't Morpheus ♪
♪ I am still the young queen,
mother, baby, what it do? ♪
♪ If you breed and don't care
for yo' seed, what is you? ♪
♪ Say it with me, a hoe ♪
-♪ A hoe ♪
-♪ This for y'all who don't... ♪
-♪ Know ♪
-♪ Big Fat, but I ain't swole,
♪ Lil' boys gon' address me
like big bro ♪
♪ Ariana ain't the only one
that do it grande ♪
♪ Knew I'd be his fiancé when he
was broke on Causeway, yeah ♪
♪ And, and, and he ain't even
hit his peak like Dante ♪
-♪ Okay ♪
-♪ And I ain't Kim ♪
-♪ What that mean? ♪
-♪ Tobe can't never go Kanye ♪
-♪ Ahh, this hoe fye, fye ♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
-♪ If you Black, we N'SYNC ♪
♪ Bye, bye, bye ♪
-♪ Everybody say... ♪
-♪ West ♪
-♪ That's my side ♪
♪ Throw it up and I'm-a put it
down until I die ♪
-To Cardi, come on.
-♪ Ahh, this hoe fye, fye ♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
-♪ If you Black, we N'SYNC ♪
♪ Bye, bye, bye ♪
♪ West, that's my side ♪
♪ Throw it up and I'm-a put it
down until I die ♪
-♪ Come on, Nessa ♪
-♪ Ahh, this hoe fye, fye ♪
-♪ Whoo ♪
-♪ If you Black, we N'SYNC ♪
♪ Bye, bye, bye ♪
-♪ Check ♪
-♪ West, that's my side ♪
♪ Throw it up and I'm-a put it
down until I die ♪
-♪ David, we go right ♪
-♪ Ahh, this hoe fye, fye ♪
-♪ Oh ♪
-♪ If you Black, we N'SYNC ♪
♪ Bye, bye, bye ♪
♪ West, that's my side ♪
♪ Throw it up and I'm-a put it
down until I die ♪
-Yeah.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]